a popular social media platform compared
to cigarettes there is now thought that
instagram may be as addictive and as
toxic and that maybe right now we're as
naive about the dangers as we were with
cigarettes some 30 years ago it's a
story every parent needs to watch
i think it's similar to what we had you
know let's say maybe in the 50s 60s 70s
where we didn't realize cigarettes
weren't necessarily hurting our health
instagram being compared to smoking
cigarettes the data is in and the
numbers show that instagram is toxic for
teen girls what they're feeling isn't
supposed to be happening right and it's
happening because they're on this app
for three years facebook studied how
instagram impacts young users the worst
part is probably how it makes you feel
about yourself sometimes 32 percent of
teen girls said when they felt bad about
their bodies instagram made them feel
worse it's called social comparison the
pressure to look perfect and when teens
compare themselves to others it can
change how they view themselves
sometimes you can like doubt your image
and your self-worth based on of what
else you see other people post
so it just creates a little bit of
self-doubt one compounding issue the
amount of time teens are on the app
adults don't typically understand that
by not being on the app you're missing
out for most kids
and teenagers they're not in charge of a
lot so the thing that they really tag
their self-esteem on is social success
teens spend 50 percent more time on
instagram than facebook and tech experts
keep your kids hooked with curated
content them finding content for you the
suggested content i think that's
something that kids really have to be
aware that what they're giving those
companies is a key to their psyche on
what will bring them back with the data
showing instagram can worsen anxiety and
depression one key remedy for mental
well-being taking a break and finding
balance i personally handle it by making
social media not my life and only a part
of my life and i can always have the
option to turn it off samantha plays
sports to get away from the screen
definitely a little bit of a lower
stress level in a small victory for
living life off a screen facebook has
suspended plans for an instagram app
tailored for even younger children for
now i wouldn't want my third grade self
being on social media just yet i feel
that kids should spend more time being
kids let kids spend more time being kids
we couldn't have said it any better
and for more help and other resources on
these types of issues head to eight news
now dot com and click on cyber safe
parent